[Music]
the 1990 fantasy film Edward
Scissorhands was a breakthrough role for
actor Johnny Depp for director Tim
Burton it was one in a series of highly
creative productions that have marked
his long career now some of Burton's
most imaginative work isn't on screen it
can be seen in real life on objects of
art and on display at a museum in Las
Vegas you know I kind of almost grew up
here I've been coming to Vegas since I
was born
Southern California native and Hollywood
heavyweight Tim Burton has a love affair
with the desert city of Light not New
Vegas but the old one I loved in neon
you know the old signs and the the
beauty of them and this sort of artistry
of them are very important to me and
part of my sort of artistic development
anyway and so the brains behind such
films as Batman Beetlejuice It's
Showtime
and The Nightmare Before Christmas Oh
through his artistic expression into the
one place he says that still represents
it the boneyard of the city's abandoned
landscape great-great-great in October
at the only Museum in the nation
dedicated to neon Burton debuted his own
artwork an assortment of animatronic
sculptures holographic drawings and
signs of all sizes are mixed in with the
permanent collection if any of this
looks familiar
you want my watch think back to Danny
DeVito's demise and Burton's cult
classic Mars Attacks
he directly nods to nostalgia by using
the actual footage of the 1995
demolition of the landmark tower you
said that had a very distinct impression
on you yeah it was like watching an
ancient dinosaur being killed there's
something it's like after it happened is
just it was silent everybody couldn't
speak was so kind of strangely powerful
sad beautiful
[Music]
for more than three decades Burton's
films have ranged from delightfully dark
to weirdly whimsical grossing more than
four billion dollars worldwide you have
Edward Scissorhands The Nightmare Before
Christmas
Frankenweenie Alice in Wonderland should
it surprise anybody that there's this
side of you well no because ithat's it
kind of brings me back to what I started
you know I've always liked to draw and
make things you know know all right
it'll begin Burton's singular style was
apparent early on his short stalk of a
celery monster helped him land a job at
Walt Disney Studios I had a room when I
was an animator and I saw from my room
where I trapped felt trapped like
Rapunzel I so you could see the hospital
where I was born and enforce law in
world my family was buried and I felt
like I was in the Bermuda Triangle you
know this weird place of life and death
fired after a few years he found his
footing directing pee-wee's big
adventure thanks for stopping that began
a string of hits that May Burton
a household name this exhibition is an
immersive experience into the mind of
timbre perhaps no one knows better than
Jenny he Burton's chief exhibition
curator what he puts on screen or on a
page or in a sculpture is identifiable
for all of his fans so there's really no
disconnect between Tim and his viewer
Tim and his visitor because of that
intense emotional connection that he
infused into his work his art has
travelled the world including a 700
piece collection that was viewed at New
York's Museum of Modern Art where it
drew the third largest crowd in MoMA's
history just behind Picasso and Matisse
he drew more than 800,000 to MoMA that
is New York City with a very
sophisticated art audience at the same
time Las Vegas draws 43 million tourists
hello Mia museum CEO Rob McCoy hopes
Burton's appeal will draw more people
here what is your favorite Tim Burton
piece it would have to be the signature
sign Las Vegas and here's the reason why
we lost the dune sign and as an homage
to the dunes he created that wonderful
outline of the old dune sign and then
just the icing on the cake he put
Stardust stars from the star design up
through the middle of it so in one
failed swoop he captured probably two of
the most famous signs in the history of
Las Vegas Jenny he says each bulb on
that 40-foot sign was sanded and painted
to look old visitors are supposed to
come in and think that this has been
here for decades what does your artwork
do for you is a therapy we asked Burton
specifically what some of those pieces
mean from the Blue Girl with wine
you know I spent a long time without
having a girlfriend so there you go to
the blue print of his most famous
creation that's one soul Edward
Scissorhands
he took on many forms as enjoying it all
reaches back to the boneyard his way of
keeping Las Vegas
past present we used to sneak into where
they kept the science if you like it 90s
it was on the other side of town and
they're beautiful you know it to me the
beautiful art what do you open people
will feel from this Vegas to me is very
dreamlike in a weird way so the memories
are like little snippets of dreams
you kind of do things and it's all very
personally and no matter what you do so
if you do connect with somebody it's
it's it's quite special interesting trip
into his mind there a little bit yeah
absolutely he has a fascinating mind and
it all comes out through his art yeah
interesting he talks about it being
therapy for him it is therapy I mean if
you you know listen to him and you
watches his movies you you his artwork
you see he's dealing with a lot I wasn't
able to break it all down like Tim
Burton know very unique show good stuff